cette semaine à l' usine de
biométhanisation thouaré bioénergétique
des camions arrivent tout droit du salon
international de l'agriculture
ils déchargent le film est collecté
durant toute la semaine porte de
versailles à paris
on a eu l'idée de se dire mais pourquoi
pas récupéré
réellement et concrètement les déchets
les fumiers les lisiers produit par le
salon pour finalement expliqué en quoi
la méthanisation
aujourd'hui elle apporte plein de
bénéfices pour un territoire et pour le
milieu agricole
une idée qui séduit le salon de
l'agriculture et touahri bioénergie 250
tonnes de fumier sont récoltés acheminés
sur le site pour être transformés en
biométhane ces fumiers sont définis
gauvin pour l'essentiel mais aussi de
d'autres natures et il s'apparente
finalement au fumier qu'on a l'habitude
de traiter ici nous au parc zoologique
de thoiry et dans toi rébus énergie bien
évidemment on fait toujours notre
mélange avec les déchets verts donc du
coup ce fumier est une très bonne base
une très bonne matrice pour la
production de biométhane sur l'usiné
dans l' usine de traitement la matière
est convoyé jusqu'à des broyeurs avant
d'être assemblés dans des mélanges euse
cette préparation est ensuite introduite
dans le réacteur principal le digesteur
les digesteurs c'est vraiment là
on va faire la dégradation de la matière
organique et la production du biogaz et
dans ceux digesteur les bactéries
séjournent
environ 21 jours
[Musique]
dégrade la matière organique
mao température vers 55 degrés jusqu'à
20 degrés celsius dans leur maison avec
hauteur sous plafond
juma et aymen les girafes du zoo safari
de thoiry ont de quoi rester au chaud
pendant un an
chauffés grâce aux déchets organiques de
leurs camarades du salon international
de l'agriculture avec ce mois de mars
capricieux elles en auront bien besoin